I came to this story this book through
originally through an interview that I
did with Peter Diamandis for the San
Francisco Chronicle and I asked him the
seemingly simple question of how did
this whole xprize thing start and he
said well how much do you know about the
private space flies flight prize and I
said not so much so he started telling
me and I'm like oh my god that is an
amazing story so Peter when he was
reading the spirit of st. Louis and late
night late nineteen ninety-three you
know he's reading his book and he lands
on this passage where he realizes that
Lindbergh didn't fly as a stunt in 1927
but he indeed flew to win this 25
thousand dollar prize and it was an aha
moment for him for sure to take a page
from the Golden Age of aviation when
after Lindbergh flew it really sparked
this commercial airline industry all of
a sudden you know everyday folks thought
you know that commercial air travel was
safe so Peter thought he could use that
model that incentive prize model to spur
innovation and spur breakthroughs in
space flight so that was really it and
the incentive prize model also has a
habit of attracting kind of these off
the grid think different types who
wouldn't necessarily do anything that is
affiliated with the government who work
in small teams who you know like to
innovate or tinker or you know they're
kind of the hackers or the makers of the
tinkers of today so it seems to attract
those types and it has throughout
history you know people didn't think
Lindbergh he was 25 years old when he
made this flight and no one thought that
he would be able to make that that you
know that that momentous flight which
after he landed in Paris made him the
most famous man on earth throughout
history there have been these the
greatest innovations which did not
involve the government
and you know whether it's the railroads
whether it's the personal computer and
whether it's with this space milestone
that was made you know the the
government actually set Peter on this
quest of his to create a private path to
space because it was the the magic of
NASA in the 1960s that first captivated
his attention and the attention of so
many people including many of the folks
who I interviewed for my book where that
Apollo 11 landing in July 1969 was it
transfixed them and it set people on
this path of the desire to get to space
it was a moment in history when
technological breakthroughs were really
at their peak and I mean what was
achieved in eight years from the time
this moon mission was announced by
president kenny Kennedy to the time you
know man for set foot on another
celestial body it was an incredible show
of ingenuity and determination and
bravery really so that was the you know
the government at its best and then
private industry you know Peters idea
going back to this particular space
prize was that where NASA had left off
NASA had gotten very big NASA had gotten
very the program's had gotten very very
costly the space shuttle mission was
extremely exorbitantly expensive it was
not as safe as everyone would have
wished and so the belief was was that
you know these small teams these kind of
Maverick individuals could then step in
and now it's interesting because you
have the NASA is Elon Musk's you know
biggest provider contractor
but I think that you know once once
SpaceX once Jeff Bezos with Blue Origin
once Virgin Galactic once these flights
become much more routine then you're
going to see it moving back away from
the government and more toward the
private citizen so the Peter Diamandis
is of the world are actually going to
get to get to fly